let's see if we can imagine a
three-dimensional shape whose base could
be viewed as this shaded in region
between the graphs of y is equal to f of
X and Y is equal to G of X so that's the
base of our this purple this I guess
move or purple color is the base of it
but then it's kind of popping out of our
screen and what I've drawn here in blue
you could view this kind of the top
Ridge of the figure and if you were to
take cross sections of the figure and
that's what this yellow line is if you
were to take cross sections of this
figure that are vertical that are that
are I should say perpendicular to the x
axis those cross sections are going to
be isosceles right triangles so this
cross section is going to look like this
if you were to look at if you were to
flatten it out so over here it's sitting
it's popping out of your page or out of
your screen but if you were to actually
flatten it out the cross section would
look like this it's going to be an
isosceles right triangle where the
hypotenuse of the right I saw sleaze
right triangle sits along the base sits
along the base so it's isosceles so
that's equal to that it's a right
triangle and then this distance this
distance between that point and this
point is the same as the distance
between f of X and G of X f of X and G
of X for this for this x value right
over there and obviously that changes as
we as we change our x value and to help
us visualize the shape here I've kind of
drawn a picture of our coordinate plane
if we're kind of if we view it as an
angle if we're kind of above it and you
can kind of start to see how this figure
would look I've once again I've drawn
the base I've drawn the base of it I've
drawn the base of it right over there
and maybe I should to make it clear and
we can like this let me shade it in kind
of parallel to these cross sections so
I've drawn the base right over there
there's two other sides there's the side
that's on at least the way I've drawn it
here I guess you could view it as its
top side or the left side right over
there and over on this picture that
would be this when we're looking at it
from above and then you have this other
side I guess on this view with this
would you could call the kind of the
right side and over here this is kind of
the when you view it over here this is
the bottom side so the whole reason why
I set this up and we're attempting to
visualize this figure is I want to see
if you can come up with a definite
integral that describes the volume of
this figure that kind of kind of almost
looks like a football if you cut it in
half or a rugby ball but it's cued a
little bit as well but what's a what's
an expression a definite integral that
expresses the volume of this and you I
encourage you to use the fact that it
intersects at the point these functions
intersect at the point 0 0 and C comma D
so can you come up with some expression
a definite integral in terms of zeros
and c's and d's and f's and G's that
describe the volume of this figure so
assuming you've paused the video and
have had a go at it so let's let's think
about it so if we want to find the
volume one way to think about it is we
could take we could take the volume of
we could approximate the volume as the
volume of these individual triangles so
that would be the area of each of these
triangles times some very small depth
some very small depth so let me just
shade it in to show the depth some very
small depth which we could call we could
call DX so once again we could find the
volume of each of these by finding the
area the cross-sectional area there then
multiplying that times a little bit a
little DX a little DX which would give
us 3 so this is a little DX which would
give us three dimensional that's our DX
I could write that a little bit neater
DX to give us a little bit of
three-dimensional depth so how could we
what is good value of one of these
figures is going to look like well if we
say let me just call this height H and
we know that
H is going to be F of X minus G of X
that's this distance right over here so
let's call that H we know that H is
going to be and maybe I should say H of
X because it is going to be a function
of X H of X is going to be f of X f of X
minus G of X minus G of X but given an H
what is going to be the area of this
triangle well this is a 45-45-90
triangle if this is 90 then this is
going to have to be 45 degrees that's
going to have to be 45 degrees and we
know that the sides of a 45-45-90
triangle or square root of 2 times the
hypotenuse so this is going to be square
root of 2 I'm sorry square root of 2
over 2 times the hypotenuse square root
of 2 over 2 times the hypotenuse and you
can get that straight from the
Pythagorean theorem if the side let's
say it's length a then this side has
length a so you're going to have a
squared plus a squared is equal to the
hypotenuse squared or 2a squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared
or that a squared is equal to the
hypotenuse squared over 2 or that a is
equal to H over the square root of 2
which is the same thing as the square
root of 2 H over 2 I just rationalize
the denominator multiplied both the
numerator and the denominator by square
root of 2 so that's where I got this
from and so what is the area going to be
well the area is just going to be your
base times your height times 1/2 so let
me write that down
so the area the area there the area is
just going to be the base which is
square root of 2 over 2 times our
hypotenuse times the height which is
square root of 2 over 2 times our
hypotenuse times 1/2 times 1/2 if we
didn't do that what half we'd be
figuring out the area of this entire
this entire square but this is obviously
we're concerned with with the triangle
so what's this going to be this is going
to be square root of 2 over 2 times
square root of 2 over 2 is going to be
1/2 and then you're going to have
another 1/2 so it's 1/4 1/4 H
weird did I do that right this is yes
it's going to be 2 over 4 which is 1/2
and then times another 1/2 is 1/4 H
squared is the area now what's going to
be the volume of each of these triangles
well the volume of each of these
triangles right over here the volume is
just going to be our area times DX or
it's just going to be 1/4 h squared
times our depth times our depth DX and
so if we just integrated a bunch of
these from our x equals 0 all the way to
x equals C we essentially have our
volume of the entire figure so how could
we write that so we want to write we
want to essentially define the volume of
the figure and it was kind of in the
homestretch homestretch here actually
let me write it right value this is
volume of a section volume of a cross
section so what's the volume of the
entire thing going to be well the volume
volume of the figure of the figure is
going to be the definite integral the
definite integral from x equals 0 to x
equals c x equals 0 to C of 1/4 H
squared 1/4 but we know that H is equal
to f of X minus G of X so instead of H
I'm going to write f of X minus G of x
squared squared DX D X and we're done
we just found an expression for a
definite integral expression I guess you
could say for the volume of this strange
figure that we have defined